um
obviously you've had a great
relationship with Thug over time uh
shout out to Young Thug free man free
slime man free free dope free slime free
Gunner
Freedom guys man free YSL for real for
real he was on the last album right yeah
yeah you guys shot the video and
everything uh he's somebody who I feel
like
super tapped in with your movement
um
I always hear just about how great of a
guy he is like he's very generous
um how did you guys initially link up oh
we I'll perform and he was like who's
that yeah he already knew who I was he
told me he told me he already knew who I
was also you opened up on tour for him
correct it was you him and MGK correct
that was before I met him I was after I
met him though right right for people
who don't know your guys's full history
yeah I met him at uh lejardin he was out
of Jordan uh they told me to pull up I
pulled up I performed
but you know what I'm saying I blew
everybody away per usual and
we uh you know shook hands
turned up after that and then it was
cool after that then
I met him again I got reacquainted with
Joe Moses I was you know sliding around
with your Moses and Joe muzzle with
future and yeah Etc you know that's the
team bargaining all them that's yeah
yeah I mean with the slimes boom and
yeah
as soon as I went to the studio he just
like you trying to record
and then that's history wow and we just
went from there and then put me on the
tour
went crazy was there a conversation to
have you maybe come over to YSL
um nah he just always tried to push my
career forward and that's devised me to
do you know make proper steps and proper
moves and [ __ ]
things that work for him things that
don't work you know and just you know
bless [ __ ] with gang and I respect
that a lot of art almost will only do
that if they have the motive of trying
to get you onto their label at the end
of the day you know what I'm saying so
the fact he does he did that like from a
selfless point of view
and I'll pick up on that too like I tell
the people I'm with y'all got a sign of
me yeah I would love you to sign with me
if you're great if you're a great talent
but you don't have to sign with me it's
just really about being under the
umbrella and you know [ __ ] with the
squad and knowing that we family and we
got your
you know what I'm saying got your back
fully